bonjour merci à tous les deux de
débattre ce matin en direct sur arte
france avec une actualité politique
assez dense la nuit dernière nouveau
coup de théâtre hier soir suspension de
séance à l'assemblée après les propos d'
emmanuel macron qui a dit vouloir l'
emmerder les non-vaccinés votre réaction
tout d'abord je pense par vous cédric
taymans pemra marine
bonjour ma réaction aux marées sont
géo pays non pays où on aime bien on
aime bien les petites polémiques depuis
le début d'année là aujourd'hui c'est
moi qui suivent les verts dès ce matin
pour répondre parce que finalement je
crois qu'on va passer encore toute la
journée
évoqué a évoqué ce fait-là cette petite
phrase cette petite phrase certains
certains la pression ferait que si
certains apprécieront aussi voulu en
parler
ça a cliqué ont parlé
durant son quinquennat
on peut la formule at il continué je
pense qu'il a il a été capable de finir
en roue s'exprimer et cette formule là
les éloigne du fond du sujet qui a été
rappelé l
intervenant quasiment
le fond du sujet c'est que l'on est
confronté depuis des mois maintenant les
meilleurs moyens de lutter contre cette
année qui fait de nombreux morts c'est
la vaccination commence mes pensées à la
vaccination je crois qu'il ya
certainement d'autres moyens d'y arriver
on va en parler parce que le modem en
plus est favorable à une vaccination
obligatoire
l'activation de
votre réaction données sismiques à cette
phrase emmanuel macron
tous et merci de me recevoir
virtuellement sur notre plateau moi je
peux comme vous que ça n'est pas une
petite formule lancée quelques nous on a
un président de la république qui vient
d'insulter les français en tout cas une
partie conséquente d'entre eux mais je
crois que si l'objectif est clair et je
rejoinds monsieur le maire c'est qu'on
détourne en réalité l'attention des
véritables sujets c'est à dire l'échec
de l'exécutif sur beaucoup de sujets à
commencer par le sujet sanitaires tout
cela est quand même très volontaire on a
un président de la république
pardonnez moi demain on a un président
de la république qui fait son entrée en
campagne tout simplement qui aujourd'hui
est clairement candidat d'ailleurs il
l'a laissé entendre dans l'interview a
été rappelé précédemment et qui fait
malheureusement une entrée en campagne
qui est à mon avis catastrophique parce
que pour qu on est avec un tel but
électoral besoin d'insulter sa
population dont je rappelle quand même
qu'il est le président de la république
enfin c'est incroyable tout cela est un
triste spectacle on va essayer une autre
phrase de manuel da cruz dans cette
interview il va assez loin d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron au point de dire que les
non vaccinés ne sont plus des citoyens
regarder
l'immense faute morale des antilles vax
ils viennent saper ce qu'est la solidité
d'une nation quand ma liberté vient
menacer celle des autres je deviens un
irresponsable un irresponsable n'est
plus un citoyen commentaire un
commentaire cédric perrin baril
de référence qui semble être dit dans
cette phrase c'est les anti pacs je
pense pas que qui est une
étude américaine particulier je pense
que ce qui est évoqué mais encore une
fois on va passer on va passer la
journée avec divers intervenants qui
vont venir commenter la pensée de d'un
homme allait poser la question président
la république
savoir et qui a voulu dire par ses parts
par ces propos là je pense que c'est le
meilleur en d'éclairer la pensée de
celui qui a tenu ses propos plutôt que
chacun y aille de son interprétation
je sais que ça nous a un qui parle des
français ça aurait été une phrase d'eric
zemmour il aurait été largement
commentés nom
de la même manière que j'aurai je suis
avait conseillé d'aller demander à
l'excès moore quel est le sens de sa
pensée
mais bon voilà il faut il faut
certainement qu'on accepte encore
aujourd'hui ce jeu qui consiste à à puis
sa nourrice la nourrice tannouri
certainement le débat puis ça nourrit
aussi à ces noyaux s'il médias donc on
va parler on va parler du pass vaccinale
à proprement parler données sismiques
votre réaction à cette à cette seconde
phrase avant de poursuivre le débat
et encore une fois je trouve que jean
c'est inimaginable on nage en plein
délire il est président de la république
depuis quand il dit qu'il décide comme
ça souverainement de retirer des brevets
de citoyenneté à des gens qui en plus
pardonnez-moi mais respecte la loi on
peut penser ce qu'on veut de deux
personnes qui refusent la vaccination on
peut trouver que ça n'est pas correct il
peut mais de là à dire qu'ils ne sont
plus citoyens parce qu'il est
responsable c'est quand même une grande
violence et encore une fois je je je
trouve que pour quelqu'un qui a fait
passer la consigne à ses équipes de dire
qu'ils aient nous on n'avait pas la
stature d'un président et nous prouve
une fois de plus qui n'a pas du tout la
stature d'un président en mer dès les
français fait c'est pas si les vents se
rendre compte de la violence de cette
phrase enfin bref eric zemmour lui il
souhaite rassembler les français autour
de son projet on va parler de la
vaccination cédric même la marine le
modem est pour une vaccination
obligatoire quand on voit les propos du
président de la république on se
demander pourquoi ne rend-il pas là la
vaccination tout simplement obligatoire
mais je pense que dans cette interview
là il explique assez clairement les
raisons pour lesquelles à son sens
rendre la vaccination cette vaccination
la obligatoire ne paraît pas annuler
paraîtrait pas pertinent juste pour
revenir on est vraiment en deux mots sur
sur la notion de citoyenneté je crois
que
dans le fond ce qu'on peut entendre
c'est que citoyen et puis on le répète
et les candidats les différents
candidats est capable de se mettre
d'accord de celui-ci à un ensemble de
droits et de devoirs et c'était pas ne
plus être citoyen dans statut mais
c'était dans l'attitude dans la
responsable et dans les terres ces
droits de deux mois
exactement
donné six les cakes et la position
d'eric zemmour justement concernant la
vaccination est ce parce vaccinale pour
ou contre
le sujet le sujet est compliqué on sait
pas un match de foot on n'est pas à fond
pour on n'est pas à fond contre il ya
des positions qui sont financés en
l'occurrence les français sont
responsables et se sont vaccinés à plus
de 90% eric zemmour lui même est vacciné
c'est aussi mon cas les françaises sont
responsables et il faut simplement
maintenant et c'est en tout cas ce qu'on
pense c'est la position d'eric zemmour
arrêtez de prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles quand on leur dit que la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire mais
pour avoir une vie sociale il faut avoir
un qr code qui montre une vaccination on
les prend un peu pour des imbéciles ce
que nous recommandons nous ce que nous
ferions si nous étions au pouvoir c'est
de vacciner les personnes fragiles en
réalité aujourd'hui on nous parle
systématiquement du nombre de
contaminations c'est un indicateur qui a
pu être intéressant mais qui est
aujourd'hui complètement désuet ce qui
compte c'est la tension hospitalière
donc nous pensons que les personnes
peuvent aujourd'hui elle est encombrée
entre guillemets la réanimation sur les
personnes âgées les personnes fragiles
avec de fortes comorbidités et que ce
sont ces personnes là qu'il faut inciter
à se vacciner avec une troisième dose
aujourd'hui il vient donc complète
discernement où on impose une troisième
dose à toulouse alors même que cette
troisième dose n'empêche pas la
contamination et c'est là quand même
tout là le caractère surprenant de ce
pass vaccinale le bassin sanitaire au
moins permettait qu'on puisse par
exemple aller au restaurant des temps
testés négatifs et on étend donc pas un
danger pour qui que ce soit là où le bât
vaccinale empêche quelqu'un qui est
testé et qui n'est pas en danger d'y
aller mais permet un vaccinés qui peut
contaminer autrui d'y aller on voit bien
qu'elle marche complètement sur la tête
cédric la marine une réaction c'est vrai
que un test d'une durée de 24 heures
avant d'aller dans un restaurant était
plus fiable pour ne pas contaminer les
autres quinqua que se faire vacciner
finalement
absolument à tester cette première étape
cette première étape du passage
sanitaire qui a quelques années c'est
vers turin qui a permis à nous a permis
d'échapper à des mesures contraignantes
avec mesure
qui en comptent dû être mise en place au
sein de l'autre pays sur sur la
nécessité d'accélérer sur la vaccination
voir constate malgré tout que se
développe se sont développées jusqu'ici
différents variant qu'il y a son but le
compliquer considérablement la vie et on
sait que le meilleur moyen de lutter
contre cette prolifération de la
variance est d'arriver à un niveau
d'immunité de la population suffisamment
important d'où la nécessité d'encourager
à la vaccination parlera par tous les
moyens et on voit que finalement
finalement ça fonctionne à au delà des
polémiques qu'on a pu avoir des
polémiques on continuera d'avoir on voit
que ça fonctionne puisque une grande
majorité de la population est vaccinée
on ose espérer que pas encore plus large
il sera dans les prochaines semaines
l'immunité collective dont parle
notamment israël y aller les députés
avaient déjà suspendu les débats sur ce
pass vaccinale est républicain le
rassemblement national et la france 1
soumises ont voté cette suspension ce
qui a mis jean castex très en colère
regarder
ces messieurs les députés nos soignants
engagé qui eux ne s'arrête pas mais lui
on vous l'avait souhaité voter
c'est irresponsable
et cédric elle peinera narines c'est
irresponsable où vous pensez cela aussi
je suis pas sûr que leur en soit dans le
meilleur parce que peut donner à
l'assemblée juste pour vous simplifier
la vie quand même juste je n'osais pas
depuis le début mais mon nom de famille
ne prend pas de faire ce qu'ils disent
mais vous simplifiez aussi la
vraiment désolé non non je vous en prie
je crois qu'effectivement au sein de
l'assemblée on est pas
on n'est pas dans
l'image que des français sont en droit
d'attendre de leur assemblée
ce qui nous évite ce qui ce qui empêche
aussi d'allouer pas de ce que dit jean
castex évidemment
là vous parlez de des députés qui ont
interrompu la séance
oui je ne parle pas un goût de
l'ambiance générale ou sam 7 à 117,9
l'assemblée et a été échangé plus avoir
entre entre entre parlementaires enfin
qui appuient avoir oscillé entre
parlementaires
données sismiques votre votre sentiment
sur ce qui s'est passé et ce qui se
passe encore à à l'assemblée comment
est-ce que cette assemblée est vu selon
vous parler français
le problème c'est pas tellement
l'assemblée récit l'exécutif ne voulait
pas que l'assemblée suspendre les débats
et après tout on peut l'entendre encore
aurait-il fallu le prisonnier public
n'insulte pas je prenne le dessus 7
millions des députés la république en
match aussi qu'il ya mise à mal alors
qu'on sait aujourd'hui que
les députés la république en marche et
sont depuis 2010 est en réalité pour
beaucoup des godillots ou en tout cas
sont pour beaucoup des députés qui ont
un professionnalisme dont on accuse vite
voir les nuits ça a été encore le cas
cette fois ci mais cette suspension de
séance elle a eu lieu aussi parce que
les débats ne pouvait pas se tenir
sereinement et l'énervement premier
ministre il est le chef d'une
provocation du chef de l'état dont que
je crois qu'il faut aujourd'hui savoir
raison garder et je tiens à parler parce
que monsieur le maire a parlé de quelque
chose d'intéressant c'est des variants
si si si l'on souhaite aujourd'hui que
ces variantes soit limitée et que ces
variants n'explose pas ou peu de
nouveaux noeuds ce que ne se développent
pas il faudrait que toute la population
mondiale soit vacciné cette pandémie
elle est mondiale n'est pas national
alors pourquoi obliger tout le monde y
compris des enfants 25 ans à faire une
troisième dose contenue pourrait donner
cette troisième dose pour avoir une
unité mondiale encore une fois on voit
bien que là il ya une incohérence et
donc les débats à l'assemblée nationale
ne pouvait pas en tout état de cause se
tenir dans de bonnes conditions cette
nuit alors que le gouvernement qui a
tendance on l'a entendu jean castex à
mettre en avant les difficultés dans les
hôpitaux le travail des soignants alors
même que ces soignants indice que le
compte n'y est pas en tout cas pour
rendre la profession attractive et
résoudre ce problème de tension est-ce
qu'il ya pas une récupération politique
finalement deux de ces tensions à
l'hôpital cédric pemba marine par le
gouvernement on sait à 100 jours de la
campagne de l'élection présidentielle
moi je très sincèrement je crois pas que
ces phénomènes de récupération politique
sur un sujet qui est un sujet est suivie
était grave un succès important et s'en
serait que le fruit sec qu'on est en
droit d'attendre de nos institutions
davantage davantage de sérénité au delà
des petites des petites phrases ou de ce
que l'on considère être un grand
événement une insulte faite à vraiment
je crois que ce qui attirait nous a
semblé c'est à s'extirper de tout ça et
à traiter les sujets
en ayant des débats entre eux qui 106 ou
la fin des décisions prises par
l'assemblée aussi librement librement
que possible moi je ne crois absolument
pas à la vanter de qui que ce soit de
surfer sur cette pandémie est plus qu
ils puissent qui entourent septembre ému
par ce que parce que la situation est
dramatique que l'on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de des conséquences des
centaines de milliers marre de des
personnes qui souffrent des familles
endeuillées je pense que personne peut
se satisfaire de ça et ce serait d'un
cynisme politique absolue que de co2 à
condition que j'ai données que vous
voyez ce qu'on a dit damien abad le
représentant les républicains à
l'assemblée et eric coquerel de la
france insoumise après la colère de jean
castex regardait ce
gros camouflet pour la majorité en
marche et le gouvernement nous les avons
mis en minorité ce soir dans l'hémicycle
sur le projet de loi passe vaccinale
amateurs un jour amateurs toujours je me
demande si jean castex n'a pas honte
si tout ça n'est pas sûr jouer pour
cacher le bilan catastrophique du
gouvernement en matière sanitaire cette
crise sanitaire est ce que ça devient un
enjeu politique de cette campagne est ce
que ça occulte osciller les autres
sujets oui clairement clairement on voit
bien que depuis depuis quelques semaines
on ne parle plus que du variant micro on
ne parle plus que du comider je voulais
dire quand même que je rejoins monsieur
le maire sur un point aujourd'hui encore
et demain on va passer toute la journée
a commenté cette petite phrase qui est
une phrase démontable certes mais qui
est fait pour ça qu'il est dépensé pour
ça qui a été pensé pour qu on la
commente et pour qu'on ne parle pas
d'autre chose qu'on ne parle pas par
exemple du fait vous parlez de
récupération de l'hôpital on parle pas
par exemple du fait que des soignants ne
sont pas du tout satisfaits du bilan du
gouvernement que les soignants ne sont
pas du tout satisfaits des moyens vital
actuellement que les soignants ne sont
pas du tout satisfaits que certains
d'entre eux étaient été suspendu pendant
une durée conséquente de plusieurs mois
donc oui cette phrase a été pensé pour
ça et en réalité elle est pensé pour que
l'on commente du superflu est pas le
fait et le font on pourrait en parler
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
le fond c'est un bilan catastrophique en
matière de sécurité en matière de
justice en matière d'immigration en
matière sanitaire et sur beaucoup
d'autres problèmes et je vois que
monsieur le maire a raison oui cette
phrase à l'échec pour ça elle est faite
pour être commentée et c'est dommage que
l'on se plier à cet exercice parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'autres choses à dire j'en
suis convaincu dans cette campagne et
nous ne nous laisserons pas confisqué
cette élection nous allons mettre en
avant nos sujets et nous ne parlerons
pas que du mobile qui est aujourd'hui
instrumentalisée alors il ya une
question sur cette crise sanitaire c'est
ce que souligne le journal britannique
le financial times qui dit que la
pandémie va jouer un rôle majeur dans
cette campagne et que les divers lance
des candidats face aux mesures
sanitaires imposées dans les meetings
pourrait même influencer le vote des
électeurs c'est vrai tout on n'est pas
d'accord sur des mesures les mesures à
appliquer pour les prochains meetings
cédric pma marine qu'en pensez vous
sur le fait certainement ses études
existent moi j'ai pas pris connaissance
de ces études mais cette fois ça pour
avoir une influence qui est certain
c'est que le colis moi je crois pas que
la la la la la phrase du président sorti
de lyn thériault d'ailleurs on retient
que cette phrase de toutes les
interviews je crois pas un dessin
semblait
croire que ma tension sur son image
c'est ce que vous dites attention je ne
dis pas que ça n'aura pas de conséquence
sur son image ce que je dis c'est que je
ne crois pas que ça il n'y ait la main
du président qui est décidé que
dorénavant les débats ne porterait que
sur la face d'eux une phrase qu'il a
prononcée sur toute une interview dans
le parisien je crois que c'est nous
c'est nous qui donnons un écho l'écho
qu'on veut
je crois en revanche que on ne pourra
pas on peut pas l'idée que ce sujet là
est un sujet de préoccupation des
français de notre quotidien et donc oui
qu'on puisse parler un peu d'eux de
cette pandémie et que cette pandémie
occupera campagne présidentielle à venir
1 une place importante ça ne me choque
le procès il va falloir qu'on puisse
parler des autres sujets aussi ce que je
crois contrairement à ce que disait
notre
notre invité sera votre travail itt et
je crois qu'il ya eu des belles
réussites aussi ce quinquennat la
toute veille de berre ici qu'il ya des
éléments et et rassembler rassembler les
français
j'entendais tout à l'heure avec propos
de marine le pen ou même
de monsieur
eric zémour rassembler les français
je crois que
c'est pas si des candidats qui
parviennent par leur position il reste
très peu de temps une minute de nice la
réponse est ce que vient de dire cédric
pemba marine et je rappelle qu'eric
zemmour a présenté ses voeux aux
militants hier et qu'il sera en campagne
en france ce week end
sur les deux éléments qui viennent
d'être dit
je pense que monsieur le maire avec tout
le respect que je vous dois cette fois
ci il faut balayer devant sa porte en
parlant de rassemblement ne peut pas
commencer à attaquer ni marine le pen ni
eric zemmour en tout cas eric zemmour ça
j'en suis convaincu c'est pas lui qui a
prononcé cette phrase c'est emmanuel
macron deuxième point sur cette phrase
et sur l'intentionnalité ou non de
l'avoir prononcée soit il savait ce que
ça provoquerait et dans ce cas là c'est
grave parce que c'est une
instrumentalisation politique soit il ne
le savais pas et dans ce cas là c'est
grave parce que ça veut dire qu'ils ne
sauront même plugin quand je t'ai 6
millions de français ça n'est pas normal
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu à distance en tout cas débattre en
direct sur arte france ce matin